to some breaking news now and an indian
court has upheld a ban preventing women
wearing headscarves in the classrooms in
the state of karnataka elizabeth peranam
is live for us in new delhi hello there
elizabeth what happened in court
hello emily well the
full bench of the karnataka high court
is still
reading its judgment but what it said so
far is that it's dismissing
various pleas by students in karnataka
who were challenging
the ban on the wearing of headscarves
and the high court went on to say that
headscarves are not
part of an essential practice in the
religion of islam and because they're
not part of an essential practice the
wearing of headscarves is not protected
under article 25 of the constitution
which gives everyone in india the right
to religious freedom now that's what we
know so far the students had been
arguing in the karnataka high court that
there is no law which prohibits them
from wearing the headscarf and also that
the constitution allows them to while
the karnataka state government was
saying that
while they agree that there is no law
that schools and colleges are allowed to
make up their own rules about the
wearing of about displaying religious
symbols now this is something that this
issue erupted earlier on this year in
udupi when
it was just one school the principal of
one school who asked students wearing
headscarves to remove them it spread to
other schools and colleges in udupi and
then in other parts of bangalore leading
to protests in support of the students
wearing headscarves and also protests
against them by hindu nationalists this
is why there is now a all schools and
colleges are closed in udupi district
today there are there is also a ban on
people gathering in a number of
districts in the state of karnataka
including the capital bengaluru another
city
mangaluru for a week with government
officials asking people not to
protest this decision but also not to
celebrate it and that is because it is
an issue that
has
polarized many people not just in
karnataka but beyond two
and elizabeth what's likely to happen
going forward are there any other
avenues of appeal or are people likely
to react
well we'll have to see what impact this
decision by the karnataka karnataka high
court has
but as i mentioned it has really
polarized people there were many
protests in karnataka in fact all
educational institutions in the state
were closed for at least a week because
of protests that were sometimes turning
turning violent and it is
you can say for certain that this is not
going to be the end of this issue
because the karnataka high court is the
highest court in the state of karnataka
but this is very likely to go to india's
top court to
the supreme court where the judges there
will have to make a decision and again
weigh up whether the indian constitution
which gives everyone the right to
religious freedom whether it will also
allow
students muslim students to wear
headscarves for now
the karnataka high court has held up the
ban saying that they're not allowed to
interestingly it also said that
students won't be allowed to wear
saffron scarves which is something that
we saw by hindu students who were
protesting against muslim students
wearing headscarves
certainly not going to be the end of
this issue thank you very much for that
update elizabeth paranam live for us in
new delhi